i'm showing you this beautiful picture
of snow-capped mountains overlooking
this alpine lake because there's a lot
of light moving around now we're going
to talk about the different ways that
light can interact with different media
but what i'm talking about can generally
be true of waves but focusing on light
for a second we've already talked about
how if we go from one medium to another
if we're transmitting from one medium to
another that the light can go through a
medium and as it goes through that
boundary from one medium to another its
direction can change and we talk about
that in another video and we call that
refraction we have refraction when we
enter the material and then we have more
refraction when we get out
now there's other things that light can
also do and that's the focus of this
video reflection and absorption now you
probably have a sense of what happens
with reflection we can see a reflection
of the mountains in the lake right over
here and the reason why we can see the
reflection of the mountains in the lake
here is because light that is coming
from this mountain
is hitting the lake and then it is
bouncing off of it and then coming to an
observer's eyeball right over here and
so they see the light that's coming from
here they see it as coming from over
here because it is bounced off and so
reflection is exactly that light is
coming in it hits that other material
and then if it bounces off that's
reflection now the other thing that
light can do is get absorbed absorbed is
when the material doesn't reflect any
and doesn't transmit any through it if
it's completely absorbing and so that
would be a situation like this now the
reality in the real world is we have
oftentimes a little bit of all of the
above happening
for example
when we look at this white snow up here
this is reflecting pretty well so
there's light that's coming from the sun
or maybe it's being reflected off the
clouds or maybe it's getting through the
clouds and when it hits that snow it
gets reflected now the reason why we
don't see a reflection the way that we
see in this lake right over here is the
snow reflects it in all different
directions but the fact that it's that
bright color in fact you might need
sunglasses to look at the snow just as
much as you need to look at the sky is
that it's reflecting most of the light
but if you go down here where we see the
trees the same light from the sky is
hitting it but not as much light is
coming back to our eye and that's
because this part of the mountain it
might be trees it might be rock it might
be dirt is absorbing more of the light
but it's still reflecting some we can
still see it a little bit so this might
be where it's most of it is getting
absorbed but a little bit of the light
gets reflected which we can see right
over there
and if we think about the water right
over here some of the light is probably
making it through and probably
refracting as it does so some of it is
getting absorbed as it makes its way
through the water if this was a really
deep lake when you get to the bottom it
could be very very dark and then as we
talked about it looks like a good bit is
reflecting when we look at the image
that we see in the lake it looks almost
as bright as the real thing so as i said
this is happening all around you in fact
when people make fancy computer graphics
they actually try to do exactly what the
light would do in the real world to make
an image for your eyes that look like
the real world and they're thinking
exactly about this how much gets through
the substance how much gets reflected
and how much gets absorbed and as i
mentioned it's not just light waves that
do this waves in general can do all of
the above